bien vamos a resolver este problema que
dice seleccionar qué fracciones sumar
para obtener 7 entre 13 713 ambos
puedes usar tantas fracciones como sea
necesario coloca las fracciones que
utilices en el bote de basura y aquí
tenemos las fracciones que vamos a sumar
para así poder obtener precisamente 7
sobre 13 y aquí las fracciones que no
vamos a usar las fracciones que vamos a
poner en el bote de basura así que bueno
arrastras fracciones que suman 7 entre
13 a la caja superior arrastras
fracciones que no utilices al bote de
basura así que bueno
lo primero que veo es que esta es mucho
más grande que 7 sobre 13 por lo tanto
más directo al bote de basura esta no la
quiero por ahorita y por otra parte
tengo estas aquí a ver tengo 4 sobre 13
esta la voy a poner aquí porque es la
más grande de las que me sobran 4 sobre
13 la voy a poner aquí y si yo me fijo
en 4 sobre 13
me faltan 3 sobre 13 para llegar a ser 7
sobre 13 y entonces si yo pongo otros
dos van a quedar 4 sobre 13 más 2 sobre
13 lo cual es exactamente lo mismo que 6
sobre 13 ok vamos bien y así sobre 13 se
le suma uno más llegó a 7 sobre 13 que
es justo lo que yo quería siente sobre
13 es la fracción que teníamos que
obtener y es exactamente lo mismo que 4
sobre 13 más 2 sobre 13 más 1 sobre 13
43 y ambos más 2 treceavos más un 13 a
vos me das 7 13 a vos que es justo lo
que yo quería y entonces ahora sí llegó
el momento de comprobar respuesta ya
pusimos lo que nos sobra en el bote de
basura y estamos bien correcto así que
así puedes hacer este tipo de ejercicios